hi I'm Erik Bosse and in Chapter two
dropped a new trailer at Comic Con
continuing this 2019 trend of horrible
things happening at carnivals now the
scares come at us very fast in the zip
Chapter two trailer and there are
actually a lot of details despite if you
look closely and because looking too
closely at this kind of imagery is very
traumatic for me I have invited my good
friend in horror movie expert marina
Mastro's to come help me break it down a
milena Erik yep we're gonna go through
this trailer shop by shot for all the
hidden clues and connections to Stephen
King source materials so this way you
guys can know what to expect when it
chapter two makes us all pissed our
pants on September 6 and yes morning we
are going to avoid spoiling the major
book plot points but you know just a
warning in case you want to go into this
movie blind might be a safe way to go
alright let's get started
something happens to you when you leave
this town far the way the hazy ur it all
gets the me and I've left I remember all
of it
okay this trailer opens with some shots
of the town of Derry and flashbacks to
Bill and Beverly as kids but now the
voice of adults Mike Hanlon is
explaining its return 27 years later the
other members of the losers Club left
the town and only Mike stayed behind as
the dairy librarian whereas the other
losers have tried to move on from dairy
and block out those painful childhood
memories mike has clung to dairy as a
sort of lighthouse keeper with a
librarian holding the keys to history
keepers of all knowledge and actually
very badass yeah there's a shot of some
missing person posters actually zooming
in hints on those you can see McKenzie
something with that five years old and
Daniel gold now Pennywise his return
means kids and dairy are disappearing
once again as with the past generation
in the first film the adults have dairy
earned er kind of paralytic spell
probably from it itself it causes them
to refuse to actually do anything about
this horrific pattern in real life if
multiple freak tragedy has happened in a
small town every 27 years
vice would be all over it and no one
would live there yeah they probably just
moved to Hawkins in the ethnic yeah
let's move
okay we find ourselves in the Barrens
the sewer system that runs underneath
Derry and if you listen closely you can
hear patty wises instrumental sting as
the water gushes in composer Benjamin
walfish created a DP sound for the
character it gives off a distorted
quality like the sound of a doll or a
jack-in-the-box as it's dying I'm like
trying to take you with it now this
moment looks like it could be penny
Mises resurrection from the Derry sewers
because next we see this drowning man
this is Adrian melon as the victim from
Stephen King's novel is actually cut
from the 90s miniseries this is a gay
man who has jumped and throw an off a
bridge by youths melons boyfriend
witnessed Pennywise feasting on him but
then he changed his story to the cops
Pennywise appears little by little as
melon surfaces reaching out supposedly
to help just like he did with Georgie
and his boat not that helpful and
interesting detail here melon is being
played by Xavier Dolan a French Canadian
filmmaker who directed films like mommy
and it's only the end of the world and
his melon surfaces over and over
notice the splashes of red in the frame
now those could be thousands of red
balloons or 99moves balloons they appear
under the bridge and the other shot of
this moment this is from the book
Pennywise unleashes balloons stamped
with a heart dairy which is the nod to
the I heart dairy hat that melon war
with his boyfriend when the thugs beat
him up and we actually saw an I heart
dairy balloon in the sewers in the first
movie through remember
the losers we made an oath I swear if it
isn't dead okay the trailer here toggles
back and forth between the losers as
adults in flashbacks of them as kids
that is now played by Jessica Chastain
Richie Tozier the jokester the group is
now played by Bill Hader whom Finn won't
part actually named as his dream choice
for its adults nice Mike Hanlon is
played by I say of estava build n bro is
now played by James McAvoy and then the
Hydra contract and he casts crack is
played by James Ransone Ben hence come
is now Jay Ryan dream casting choices
I'm sure the child actors were thrilled
to see how hunky many of them become
it's like they all yelled Shazam
just another 2019 carnie film yeah weird
now Stanley Harris is now played by Andy
bean in this film and you'll notice that
adult Stan Lee does not join the other
losers in a lot of these shots there's a
reason for that but we don't want to
spoil it just lit they reconnect in this
Chinese restaurant where Mike reminds
them of their blood oath to return to
Derry and defeat the monster if it ever
returned book readers will know this
setting as another frightening moment
and attendees at comic-con got to see an
extended version of it and we aw come on
let's move on if it ever comes back
we'll come back to you we didn't stop it
we can't let it happen again
okay here's a shot of Mike with police
lights reflecting in his face making me
think that he might be a witness to the
Adrian melon crime scene and he might
recognize it as penny wisest return
leading to him calling the other losers
to honor the oath and then we go to of
course a nightmare carnival with a
nightmare funhouse whose entrance is
eight nightmare clown mouth probably
reflecting the way Pennywise wants to
literally consume them and fun detail
here the swinging clown dummies are
designed to specifically resemble the
Tim Curry penny wise from the 90s TV
mini-series first film also featured a
Tim Curry
Easter egg in the Richie clown doll room
in the niebolt house we see more of this
not at all fun house in the next clip
hello
okay this Hall of Mirrors scene is
another sequence at Comic Con attendees
got to see a fuller version of James
McAvoy said that originally bill wasn't
gonna be in the scene at all but
director Andy machete added him to give
bill's character another moment to show
his lingering survivor's guilt for him
penny wise has manifested as less of a
direct threat to him than the fear of
living without a loved one really the
parental fear of losing the child so in
the same Pennywise tortures bill by
making him watch another kid being
attacked the directory is is an
interesting lighting effect having the
lights flicker out like and now you see
it now you don't magic trick first we
see penny wise on the other side of the
glass then just the kids reflection and
then on the third flicker huge monster
penny wise eraser gene the directory is
this exact same trick with the projector
slides in the first film with the lights
up lights down transition to reveal a
suddenly giant monster penny wise which
freaked me out oh yeah this whole idea
of an adult having to watch helplessly
could be a version of the deleted scene
from the first film which showed a young
mother in the Puritan colony in 1637 of
Derry when she allowed it which was then
a shape-shifting shadow to devour her
baby to spare the rest of the colony
this is essentially the whole threat of
chapter 2 even if the adults are no
longer scared of the monster they must
reckon front their fears in order to
save future generations
women are 20
I dreamt of you I craved you
[Music]
okay there's a lot going on in this clip
the adult losers return from the well
house on niebolt street after having
already faced it notice Eddie has a
wound on his sheet and mike has a
bandaged wrist and a big reveal here
again
spoiler alert a red balloon floats past
this criminal psychiatric institution
where the adult Henry Bowers sees it yes
Henry does survive falling down the well
in the first chapter and in the novel he
takes the fall for all of penny wises
murders in that generation remaining
under the trance in allowing the town to
ignore the real conspiracy it was also a
shot of the losers in the niebolt house
seeing the fridge shake the same fridge
at penny wise contorted to himself in to
fit inside an extended cut of this scene
was shown at comic-con featuring a
severed head with spider legs extending
out which he says you gotta be kidding
it's meant as an homage to the scene and
John Carpenter's The Thing penny wise
talks about how he dreamt of mist and
craved the losers which is like pretty
creepy coming out of history yeah
meaning that them defeating him as kids
just made him have a grudge for a super
long time and now he's awake and gonna
act it out there's a shot of young Bev
floating under the spell of the dead
light switch in the book are supposed to
kill anyone who sees them the fact that
Bev survived could mean Pennywise attack
marked her with a lasting scar yeah and
we returned to the three doors of the
niebolt house very scary scary and not
scary at all which I don't trust those
labels yeah yeah not a little bit none
of them good which led to specific
scares for the kids in Chapter 1 we'll
see how those scares evolved for chapter
2 onto the next clip
we need to finish
all of us
zoomy inside so we don't have a choice
any minute okay here the losers explore
its subterranean cavern layer with the
shark formations in them this could be
pieces of like a husk or maybe a cocoon
for its massive final form from the book
and miniseries which either of us are
that eager to see yes or no kind of a
scary yes and no thing then there are
some shots of scenes we saw in the last
trailer Ritchie sing Pennywise float
pass dairies Paul Bunyan statue and
Beverly visiting mrs. Kirsch that no one
wants to ever go back to see notice how
mrs. Kirsch keeps her frozen inhuman
smile and sped passes through the
doorway someone should tell Pennywise
that smiles are only supposed to last
like a half second tops anything longer
is serial-killer long still Eric Eric no
have a good guy and before we move on
there's a shot of a bloody hand dripping
from a tub now this is most likely a
major bone from the book again we don't
want to spoil it just yet but know it's
gonna be something foreign you'll know
when you see it
[Music]
okay in this section there's a quick
shot of a loser scrambling deeper into
the cavern oh this could be during the
final battle and notice how the framing
here makes the opening here look like an
eye hole almost like the losers are
plunging deeper into the dead lights
pretty cool another shot shows bill
revisiting the flooded basement scene of
chapter 1 with his younger self behind
him and Georgie and Pennywise in the
corner
Georgie's voice haunts you lied and I
died this reflects the survivor's guilt
that plays bill as he struggles to
overcome a shame covering up the real
thing that killed his brother yeah then
we see Beverley revisiting one of her
painful memories from chapter one in the
bathroom stall she just like cannot
escape oh yeah just blood showers all
the time
notice the graffiti hate clown with some
[ __ ] talked about other girls named
Bridget and Greta who honestly could be
guilty of nothing at all and they're
just an innocent victim in this graffiti
crime in the case yeah this could mean
that other kids in Derry have spotted a
clown around the town and are creating
pages in their burn book about them yeah
probably and this bathroom fills with
blood with adult Bev reliving the bloody
bathroom moment of chapter 1 there's a
shot of two hands reaching out to each
other
perhaps to reflect adult Bev reaching
out to save her younger self and the
adult is trying to recover from the
trauma she experienced as a child I just
suggest instead that originally the
director was only going to have the
blood go up to her neck chest and said
no let's make this Carey on steroids and
then Bev shatters a mirror where in the
reflection you can see what looks like
Ben and Penny wises clutches as Mike
struggles to free Emma no I say Ben
because that he can look past that
washboard good luck there looks to be
some scarring which Pennywise might have
done is a callback to Henry Bowers tummy
cuts can we just like take a moment to
reflect on the ABS for a minute because
they're there and we don't want to pause
there yeah not that missable wasn't you
doing maybe benefit smashing the mirror
because they can't see penny was in real
life only in the mirror and by
shattering the illusion of him they
break free of the fear that he has them
under because it's the fear that
Pennywise represents that's the real
threat oh like someone should make a
famous quote about fear it
one day one day moving on to the last
section
[Music]
okay here there are some shots of adult
losers United and Bev underwater at some
gum looking of corpses attacks are the
losers run in fear as the rock formation
in the cavern Dee materializes around
them and Mike looks up as Pennywise pops
out of an air vent on the wall this
looks like the ruins of the black spot
the dance club that was burned down in a
past Pennywise attack and we see a shot
of someone rising up a will shaft where
the light now I'm wondering if this
could be like a reversed shot of the
moment Mike pushed Henry Bowers down the
well shaft in chapter one and maybe this
rise represents Pennywise resurrecting
him to have someone take the fall for
him there's also a very quick shot of
Mike screaming in the sweaty trippy tent
shelter now if you're at the book you'll
know about the smoke hole sequence in
which the losers construct a Vision
Quest clubhouse thing to try to
understand its cosmic origin it's pretty
bonkers maybe result of Stephen King's
influences from Hades and her very eager
to see how it temperature will try to
adapt Kings very interesting mythology
then there's a shot of Pennywise burying
us alive in a grave shutting the hatch
over us then the trailers closing shot
with Bill skarsgård laughing and face
paint his forehead and cheeks ripped
open and Lady scars matching his iconic
red clown makeup
skarsgård also does his unnerving eye
trick where he can focus one eye forward
and the other eyes skewed to the side
just kind of floating yeah that's crazy
now in the other trailer mrs. Kirsch
told Bev that her father joined the
circus as a clown now that was just a
story that Pennywise was telling Bev to
try to mess with her but maybe Pennywise
is taking this human form in order to
further Todd Bev playing into this
narrative as an insane man putting on
clown makeup and scarring his own face
you think about it's actually a bit
similar to the Heath Ledger take on the
Joker in the Dark Knight remember he
actually specifically implied that he
applied his own makeup with the detail
of pink smeared on his fingers and under
his fingernails
he was an unreliable narrator who
invented his backstories that he
actually gave himself his own facial
scars what scene are you most and least
looking forward to an it chapter 2 let
us know in the comments down below
yeah thanks for joining me to help break
down this tremor you know this is great
I'll break down anything yeah you made
this littlest airplane
he's still pretty terrified only
slightly yep follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a vas and follow me on
Twitter at Marina masterís and subscribe
to new rock stars for breakdowns the
theories about everything you love
thank you for watching an marina tell me
exactly when my smile becomes too green
now
[Music]